bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale championnat du monde féminin
2016 première partie aujourd'hui entre
les deux finalistes de ce championnat du
monde alors maria musou que
l'ukrainienne face à ivan ou la chinoise
alors est ce qu'il faut savoir pour ce
championnat du monde sait que donc
mariam ou zouk et la championne en titre
du fait qu'elle a gagné le tournoi qu'on
a suivi d'ailleurs l'an dernier par
élimination en gagnant la finale de ce
tournoi mais où ifan ou dit fan où il
faudrait dire plutôt puisque des fans
c'est son prénom
la chinoise qui était champion du monde
en titre avant ce tournoi ne l'a pas
joué
pourquoi parce qu'il était déjà prévu
que elle elle devait donc jouer en match
et bien la championne issus de ce
tournoi donc là on a un match de
championnat du monde qui correspond bien
plus au format normal d'un championnat
du monde
mais du coup dans ce championnat dans
l'histoire du championnat féminin on a
ici une espèce de formule un peu bancal
ou encore apparemment on alterne matchs
et tournois bon alors donc ce match va
avoir lieu donc en 10 parties donc la
championne du monde en titre maria musi
tout face à la sortante en quelque sorte
elle était déjà championne du monde
avant l'ifa nous et qui nous fait nous
est favorite puisqu'elle a un placement
lots très supérieure à celle à celui de
marianne ou zouk ce qu'elle doit être
pas loin de deux mille sept cents lots
un peu moins peut-être à 2600
j'ai pas le score exact ce procédé 1673
voilà pour iphone ou contre 2554 pour
maria musi tout mais bon il ya à peu
près 100 points sans point il ya encore
plein de plein de possibilités 1 ici
pour mariam ou zitiou pourquoi pas donc
c'est parti dans cette première partie
qui vous allez voir quand même est un
peu terne
à la fois en termes de résultats mais
c'est à la limite c'est pas très grave
on peut avoir une belle partie même si
on a une partie nulle mais elle est un
peu terne en terme de jeu alors c'est
parti donc eu quatre choisi eux cinq ils
répondent donc par là l'asymétrie la
chinoise maria muzitu de suivi par
cavalli f3 cavalli c6 alors voilà donc
là on peut se demander si les blancs
vont rentrer dans la grande variante fou
b5
c'est à dire la rue lopez puisque oui
c'est quand même le nom la rue lopez
c'est fou b5 alors après il ya plein de
variations la fameuse de varen de berlin
joué ces dernières années beaucoup ou à
6 la grande variante de la rue lopes
alors donc je vous invite évidemment à
voir la conférence que j'ai donné un an
si dans six 2016 sur rui lopez et
philidor voilà une conférence d'une
heure qui a bien plu apparemment et donc
voilà qui est qui a été mis en ligne
récemment que vous pouvez découvrir
mais là c'est parce que choisit
marjanovic qu'en tout cas pour cette
première partie ces dix parties dans le
match peut-être a changé et la foux ces
quatre mois l'a donc poussé quatre on
n'est plus dans un des bus de type
classique italien donc c'est moins les
grandes variantes
alors c'est peut-être pour éviter dans
cette première partie je sais pas où ces
cinq voix l'a alors poussée 5
alors c'est un coût qui est sans doute
le plus dynamique
on peut aussi jouer qu'avec les 6 ou
savez peut-être d'autres coups aussi
jouer des six qui sont peut-être moins
moins précis bien sûr parce que si on
vous des six ans ferme le fou mais ça se
joue tout à fait donc bien sûr alors
poussé 5
alors là on peut se prendre des coups
comme b4 voilà surtout ces cinq il ya le
fameux gambie evans b4 qui a l'air de
rien mais que quand même été joués afin
qu'à l'air de rien si c'est un gambit
très important qui a été jouée par
fisher notamment mais aussi par kasparov
kasparov qui a eu des victoires
retentissantes notamment face à un
hollande et en championnat du monde
voilà donc b4 alors si il n'a pas joué
non plus des masses c'est un coût qui
surprend c'est l'adversaire ne s'y
attend pas mais voilà donc poussé cinq
bons donc alors là que va jouer
my house hitchock alors là on voit on va
voir la suite tout de suite avec
simplement petit rock voilà donc on
rentre pas dans les grandes variantes
elle aurait pu tenter b4 ou peut-être
ces trois on peut aussi jouer ses trois
avaient l'idée des quatre ce genre de
choses donc là tranquillement les noirs
continuent khalef si son attaque le pion
aux quatre centres attention voilà coup
tranquille detroit alors c'est pas les
variantes les plus aigus mais là on est
sur du calme ça se joue pas mal
apparemment ces derniers temps et
notamment des joueurs comme carsen ne
renierait pas ce type de début parce que
finalement bon ben on retarde un petit
peu le combat a plus loin on n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de combat direct d'un
ouverture ya pas de tentatives des
blancs d'oeufs de surprendre les noirs
et de forcer comme sale avantage tôt
dans la partie
petit rock et la c3 voilà ce 3 ce coût
est essentiel pour les blancs pour
essayer d'obtenir quelque chose on joue
ces 3 alors que les blancs les noirs
peuvent pas jouer c'est 6 du fait qu'ils
ont sorti leurs pièces menace et qu'ils
étaient par les blancs au centre c3 et
l'idée mais sur ces deux jouets des
quatre avec gain de temps puisque en cas
de prise prises le cavalier tient la
dame aussi et le fou devra bouger les
blancs gagner du temps des six et la
hache croire leurs joueurs 3 d'abord
parce que si on joue des cas tout de
suite bien après des quatre ans prises
prises le fou par le pion aux quatre
étant prises pour le protéger et après
les noirs pourrait jouer au foot j'ai 4
ans et un clouage désagréable parce que
ce cavalier c'est quand même le
défenseur de la casse des quatre on a
poussé le pion donc c'est quand même un
peu un peu embêtant il
h3 un peu nécessaire si on veut
envisager de jouer des quatre pour
consolider la position de ce cavalier
c'est important h6 voir le pareil pour
les noirs pourquoi pas envisager pour le
noir plus tard de jouer des cinq bombes
et il faut pas se prendre un coup g5 qui
enlèverait de la défense à la casse des
cinq taureaux on consolide le pion aux
quatre on met une tour vers le centre on
consignes de 4 toujours dans l'idée de
jouer des cadres comme ça le pion et
cassera déjà protégés ça c'est des coups
de début assez normaux il n'y a pas
besoin d apprendre par coeur ce genre de
coup d'ailleurs
en général je conseille pas d'apprendre
les coûts d'ouverture par coeur ils vont
me connaître les grands principes
voilà c'est des coûts de préparation tôt
ou tard les blancs on veut jouer des 4 à
6 alors à 6 l'idée pour les noirs c'est
en cas de b4 des blancs le fou va en b 6
à 4 et après qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
le four serait obligé de jouer à 6 à ce
moment là alors que la maintenance sur
b4 on jouera fois c'est tout de suite
donc le fou ce ménage en fait une petite
case en assez net voilà c'est l'idée de
ce coup et pourquoi pas éventuellement
de jouer des scènes mais surtout joué
fois cette voie là et garder une case
pour ce fou qui en ce que les noirs ont
joué des six donc se fout un problème
ici on peut parvenir par là en cale
attaque donc ici on va rester ici on a
quand même très très belle diagonale se
foutrait forains attention et parce
qu'il tape sur f2 est le roi derrière il
contrôle une case au centre c'est une
pièce majeure du côté noir ici qui est
extrêmement puissante voilà à 4,1 très
bien mais bien quatre on voit que les
blancs mais veulent profiter de jouer b4
avant de jouer des cadets cap si on the
decade d'abord après prise prison pourra
plus jouer b4 et on prend un peu d'air à
l'aide d'amis 6 à 4 on empêche bessèges
notamment aux siens on empêche les noirs
eux mêmes de prendre de l'air allèles
dame et puis on veut peut-être commencé
à avancer ses pions les dames fois la
fois cette voie là donc on coud
prophylactique c'est à dire qu'on on
anticipe le coup et b4 qui pourrait
venir en n'importe quel moment en jouant
fois cette bombe sur b4 rien attaqué et
on peut on peut voir venir
voilà qu'avec les d2 voilà on développe
tranquillement il ya les blancs se
pressent pas à jouer des coûts centraux
continuer leur développement
tours 8 voilà les noirs tranquille aussi
consolide aussi plus tard ils pourront
peut-être jouer des cinq et il vaut
mieux consolider au 5 avant câblier fin
alors ça c'est classique dans les débuts
on est typique dans les idées d'espagnol
ici accueil des deux cabinets fin l'idée
c'est qu'on peut vouloir me jouer le
quart et son âge 2 soit éventuellement
le 3 pourquoi pas ou angers 3 by ap les
trois cases intéressante
parfois on vient h2 pourquoi pas pour
viser la case g4 mais souvent six
cavaliers là qui vient en h2 ça on joue
qu'un léger 3 l'autre cavaliers vian h2
et aprilia angers cas puisque comme ça
la dame contrôlent la quasi 4 ainsi que
le pion h3 et parfois on peut monter les
ac comme ça c'est typique des idées de
l'espagnol et on est dans un des bus
pagnol je vous le dis un peu dès le
début avec cinq cavaliers six bons même
si les blancs ont pas joué foulée 5 mai
on a d un peu les mêmes idées que
l'espagnol en ce type d'ouverture
alors faut aussi ce voilà alors il faut
tuer se fout parce qu'on voit bien
qu'avec l'idée de ces cavaliers qui vont
monter comme on vous expliquait même si
celle en battant ou tard une attaque
contre le roi qui pourrait se dessiner
un petit peu elle se fout tape sur f7
c'est quand même embêtant donc il est
important de les changer
d'où en plus se fout c'est 8 n'a pas de
perspective les noirs peuvent pas à
monter d'attac vraiment et non pas le
temps de toute façon faut éliminer ce
fou qui est plus actif que le fou de
cases noires que le fou noir pardon le
fou de on élimine les foudres cases
blanches c'est bon pour les noirs prises
on prend de la tour bien sûr pour pas
doubler les pions et affaiblir le roi
est maintenant faut 3 pareil pour les
blancs voilà on échange ce x 7 qui est
très dangereux et voilà on n'a pas envie
de garder ce fou qui bon si on veut
monter une attaque qu'alléger trois cas
les f-5 avait l'idée de sacrifice 1 h 6
parfois ce fou peut aider mais ce fou
c'est vraiment à cet égard même aussi
très dangereux contrôle des quatre bons
on veut l'échanger
bon pourquoi pas on essayé de simplifier
la apparemment la position on reprend du
cavalier voilà donc maintenant scaglia
deux cases en f 50 dessins faut faire
attention à l'environnement la position
c'est quand même simplifiée mais bon il
peut quand même toujours y avoir des
idées d'attac 1 voilà des 5 voilà noir
réagissent proprement au centre des
seins qu'on laisse pas les blancs
s'installer soins des 5.5 ont réagi au
centre très vite et pourquoi pas en
menace de prendre au centre d'échangés
les dames et d'aplanir la position comme
ces deux dames 17 se presse pas lifan la
chinoise elle joue d'abord dame 17 elle
veut amener peut-être sa deuxième tour
sont à 8 soit en des huit avant
d'envisager de prendre en quatre tours
d1 alors là maintenant un petit
vis-à-vis tour dames
attention
mais bon ça gêne pas elle joue autour
des 8 il entend qu'elle prend pas y'a
rien de toute façon
et puis on peut façon n'y a pas de
danger particulier qualif c'est voilà
c'est ce que j'avais dit à l'heure ce
cas il y avait deux cases des 5 et f5
voilà alors si on avait gardé le fou
dont on pourrait envisager des
sacrifices sur l'a6 on envoie des fois
des partis comme ça mais est-ce pas
pareil que d'avoir éliminé ce fou quand
même ce fourrage 7 qui contrôle
notamment la casse des quatre
importantes
l'académicien qu'en tout cas c'est un
cavalier menaçant on peut pas bouger
ainsi on joue j'ai six compères le pion
aux 6 et ce pion et menaçant une attaque
regarder ça fait ce cavalier au regard
des acquis l'attaquant même ici deux
pions il a de belles perspectives là il
et il est fort c'est toujours pénible
d'avoir un cavalier en 9 5 face à soi
c'est kasparov qui disait que il
considérait on pouvait considérer qu'un
cavalier en 9,5
valais un pion voilà bon alors c'est
peut-être pas vrai dans cette position
puisque déjà les deux fous ont été
changés c'est plus difficile à monter
une attaque mais bon c'est quand même
une remarque de kasparov qu'il faut
qu'il faut méditer dames 8 lames 8 voilà
on enlève le vis-à-vis tournant puisque
on veut sans doute prendre au centre et
l'échangé une paire de tours peut-être
doubler les tourner cette tour pourra
non peut pas justement la pointe on peut
pas à cause de ça alors à noter que les
noirs peuvent quand même un petit plan
pour dégager ce cavalier aussi on peut
jouer trois sets simplement et j'ai 6
mai et la dame pourrait venir sur ses
seins et on aura un problème on pourrait
avoir un problème sur un châssis sont
encore c'est quand même dangereux
voilà bk trois là donc ça c'est l'idée
qu'on avait dit à l'heure aussi on avait
sept soukouss étroits tant qu'on n'a pas
joué des quatre avec les blancs et puis
si apparemment c'est pas leurs idées
ben on peut aussi envisager de prendre
de l'espace à les dames ici donc on a
deux pions qui bien avancé on a choisi
une attaque spatiale ici un bon il n'y a
pas de gros danger pour l'instant on se
positionne assez symétrique
mais l'élan une petite pression et se
passe à lille dame cavaliers le
cinquième place et attention mais le
centre est quand même il n'est pas fermé
donc les blancs pas vraiment les mains
libres à tout moment les noirs peuvent
échanger au centre créé beaucoup de
d'échangés attention parce que si on en
voit tous ses pions d'un côté quand la
simplification arrive à la fin il
faible ses pions plutôt que d'être un
avantage ça peut devenir une faiblesse
des cinq les noirs fixe fixe l'avancé à
l'avancé blanche ici prise prise il ya
plus les blancs iront pas plus loin
et maintenant cavalier des dehors
pourquoi pas alors qu'avec 200 me paraît
quand même ici se coupa pas forcément le
meilleur la cale et des deux c'est comme
un peu passif l'as cavaliers bon et
pourquoi pas mais il veut venir regarder
très certainement son cavalier bon
protège le quatre-mâts limite ce n'est
pas l'idée on va venir en b3 et surtout
ans et 5 mois la très belle case et la
tour est prise au regard des sept tours
seraient sous la prise du cavalier c'est
simple et ya plus de cases en 7 ou en d6
si les prix elle est prise cette tour
par le cavalier f5
donc attention gros danger cavaliers b3
menace un gros cavalli ces cinq-là donc
là les noirs réagissent immédiatement
par caillou cette normale on profite du
fait que le câble et n'attaquent
piocelle est né en cas de prise en scène
ya pas de double attaque sur sur cinq
donc on peut jouer cavalier 7 du fait
que ce cavalier bouger et surtout qu'est
ce qu'on veut faire échanger lecavalier
dans ce cas là si le cavaliere est lancé
c'est bon on pourra bouger la tour il ya
plus de problème on peut bouger sur la
6ème n'importe où et on élimine en plus
potentiellement ce cavalier f5 voilà
prise dans prend à tranquille et
maintenant voilà ça y est c'est l'idée
câble et b3 on veut venir en c5 attaqué
la tour et mon ses propres la partie est
propre il n'y a pas de billets pas
d'erreur de parts et d'autres
mais c'est vrai que c'est un quand même
un peu un peu terne parce que bon mais
il ya quand même une grosse symétrie ya
pas de voiliers que l'on niveau pioncer
symétrique et pas de n'y a pas de
distorsion on peut pas dire qu'il est
d'aider a pas de faiblesse voilà rien
n'y a rien à l'attaqué ni d'un côté ni
de l'autre
un petit peu cette petite case c5 un
petit peu fait mais bon ce cavalier en
c5 est ce qu'il va vraiment menacer les
choses surtout qu'on va doubler à bien
on pourra pas parce que sûr que les
sections double attention hein
quelle section bourg ici avec la tour on
se prend une belle fourchette en baisse
est donc on pourra pas en faire on n'y
est pas encore voilà prise d'abord voilà
on va simplifier prise et maintenant
voilà maintenant tour des 6 les bleues
ont pas le temps ils n'ont pas du tout
le temps et puis là on va échanger de
toute façon au moins une tour voilà qu'à
laisser 5 à la bombe
on peut menacer calais b 16 mai c'est
pas une vraie menace parce qu'on
pourrait changer
mais là les noirs échanges prise et ils
échangent encore prise
et voilà la position est complètement à
plat ni assez difficile d'envisager quoi
que ce soit maintenant regarder surtout
la position est symétrique 1 2 pions
contre deux pions capillon contre 4
pions et les dames cavaliers hilairois
sont pas faibles
ah c'est vrai que c'est difficile
d'envisager autre chose que la partie
nuit ici d'amd 6 à la proposition de des
changes lorsque les blancs auraient pu
est-ce qu'on peut envisager ici on peut
regarder un échange ici de dames
pourquoi pas ça serait dangereux parce
que si après prise ici le cavalier est
attaqué et regardez le pion à 4 étant
prises donc si on va par exemple en b
cette attaque et des six on est obligé
de bouger
simplement on prend 1,4 qui protège des
six et en plus qui a taxé 3 c'est une
catastrophe donc on peut pas avec les
blancs et changer les dames
parce que ça faut toujours envisager
parce que la symétrie serait cassée et
ça peut être intéressant mais là on peut
pas il faudrait que le pion soit 23,6 le
puritain f3 on pourrait envisager
d'échanger pourquoi pas aller chercher
des complications se sait pas mais en
l'occurrence c'est pas envisageable donc
c'est pas ça du tout qui a été joué
voilà c'est donc après d'amd 6 bien sûr
c'est dans me2 voilà les deux
tranquillement et ses 6 soit la bombe et
poussé 6 on consolide bessin qui était
attaqué par l'adam attention la dame
avait notion du sien consolide
tranquillement car la dame sous la
colonne n'y a pas de problème la g3
cavalli 17 ont proposé chiffrage de
cavaliers bon là il change de cavaliers
voilà la tension la dal attac h3 la
grosse menace là que va faire mariam ou
zitiou courage et 2
on ne peut pas dire que ce soit très
attendu et après d'anne decis dames 3 et
bien les joueuses combien
ici d'une particule en en 31 coups donc
c'est un petit round d'observation
on ne peut pas dire que marion bouzigues
chouk avec les blancs et chercher à
prendre un avantage dans cette partie
les noirs n'ont commis aucune faute pas
de problème bonne partie nulle pour les
noirs finalement on va voir ce que va
faire maintenant
lifan ou avec avec les blancs dans la
partie suivante sachant que c'est elle
la favorite et ça m'étonnerait qu'elle
joue
calmos à mon avis ça va jouer sec et ça
va être une partie extrêmement tendue je
suis pas sûr que cette partie là de
rendre d'observation soit soit une bonne
idée pour moi nous y trouvons ceci
dirais pas fait de fautes c'est
peut-être ce qu'elle voulait jouer dans
le match
peut-être voulu voir ce que jouer les
noirs et puis elle va dérouler la suite
ça fait partie aussi attention des
stratégies de match mais si un match
course et 10 parties donc est ce qu'on a
le temps comme ça de faire des rendre
une observation bon alors à cinq fois
les blancs la plus que quatre fois les
bleus voilà bon voilà bonbons deux
parties maintenant il faut attendre la
suite pour que le vraiment le match se
décante et cons et qu'on assiste à du
jeu a du beau jeu a du jeu intéressant
mais en tout cas ce championnat du monde
2016 c'est parti et la chinoise est
favorite est toujours après cette
première partie on peut considérer que à
la marque et un bon demi point voilà
merci donc de nous avoir suivis pour
cette première émission de canal tv sur
ce championnat du monde féminin 2007
j'espère que ça vous a plu j'espère que
vous pourrez comme ça suivre le match
le soir en rentrant ou le soir
en rentrant pas comme vous voulez mais
en tout cas voilà un petit résumé plutôt
garder la partie comme ça à sec
et voilà et on essaiera de faire comme
ça un petit un petit bilan de ce
championnat du monde
à bientôt au revoir